皆さん、世の中には
色んな種類のお菓子
あると思います
だが！
１番お手軽で誰でも簡単に買えるお菓子
何か分かりますでしょうか
そう！
うまい棒です！
私は思ってしまった
うまい棒安くて美味しいですよね
10円で１個
100円で10個
1000円で･･･
100個食べれちゃう･･･！
安いっ！
そこで私は思ってしまった･･･
うまい棒10万個って
素直にそう思ってしまった！
はっ！
（？）
はい、というわけで
えー100万円企画
「うまい棒100万円買ってみた」でございます！！
【本日の謝罪動画】
すいません！
やりたくて！
やってみたくて！
やってみたくなったんです！
悪気は無いんですよ･･･泣
あの純粋に個人的に
うまい棒･･･100万円分買ったら
どれぐらい･･･の量になるのか
なぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
って思って
買ってみました
もう業者さんが来てるんで
取りに行ってみましょう！
（この人狂ってますね）
ホントちょっとした出来心なんですよねぇ･･･
うわっ！
あのトラックか！
でけー･･･
え？んん･･･
２台･･･おはようございまーす
業者「あ、どうもー」
業者「こちら･･･」
や～ばっ！
( ´•ω•` )
( ՞ةڼ◔  )
※早送り
これのあと･･･
２倍あるみたいです
ちょっと思ったより多いっすね
※早送り
※あ、チーズ味だ　↑
いやそれは･･･
ありがたいです･･･
大家「あ、本当に！？」
大家「ｗｗｗ」
大家「挑戦します･･･」
ｗｗありがとうございます！
大家「いやここまでメチャクチャなんだよ･･･」
うーん･･･
※早送り
100万円分うまい棒買うのが
もうネットだと無理だったんで
直接
うまい棒を作ってる会社
リスカさんから
発注いたしました
リスカさんありがとうございました！
はい、というわけで
うまい棒100万円分届きました
表面だけでもこれです
この中に、もううまい棒が詰まってるんですけど･･･
中を見てみましょう
やば、もう･･･
狭すぎる
はい、ここから全部･･･
うまい棒になってます･･･
ええぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇええ？
これちょっと･･･
どうするのこれ？
ここも全部うまい棒･･･
はい、というわけで
うまい棒100万円分買ったので
今からこの部屋にうまい棒100万円分
運びます！
いやこの一般的な部屋に
うまい棒持ち込むと
どれくらいの量になるのかなっていうのを見たい･･･
･･･
だけです
いきますっ！！
うわあ･･･
ベッドの端っこから置いてった方がいいんだ
端っこから
うわあ･･･
ふうっ！
待って！
ダンボール一個でこのレベルか！
※早送り
はっはっはっはっは･･･
うわこれやばいマジで！
家が埋まる多分
※早送り
やばいっ！
うまい棒だけは踏まないようにしよう
※早送り
※残り9万9999本になったじゃねえか！
LOADING...
↑
！？
やべっ
はい、というわけで
えー･･･
部屋にうまい棒100万円分入れてみたんですけど
いやー、多いっすね
さすがにうまい棒たくさん買うと
完全に「うまい山」になってしまいました
とりあえず100万円あれば
まあ･･･
部屋いっぱいうまい棒だらけになるなっていうのは
分かりました
今からつる兄が家に来るんですけど
多分久しぶりにつる兄遊びに来るんですよ
もしもし？
今どこー？
ちなみにつる兄さー･･･
好きなお菓子何？
うん
はい、というわけでうまい棒好きみたいですね
（うまい棒チョコレート味あるからね）
これだけの量のうまい棒があると
人ってパニくると思うんですよ
多少の量だったら
ワアッ！てなると思うんですけども
信じられない量のうまい棒を目の前にして
えー彼は
第一声何を話すのか？
とても気になるところでございます
それでは
彼が来るのを待ちましょう
※ご臨終
つ「こっちですね？」
つ「っははっ･･･ｗ」
【第一声】
えっへへへへへｗｗｗ
ははははははｗｗｗ
うまぁ･･･♡
つ「･･･ｗ」
つ「っふふ･･･ｗ」
つ「ええ？」
んまあ･･･♡
【ED】
つ「あっはははははｗｗｗｗ」
つ「いやドッキリに手間かけすぎじゃないですか？」
いや･･･
つ「えっ！？」
いや100万円企画なんだよ原の
つ「ｗｗｗｗ」
つ「あーはいはいはい」
あの、100万円分･･･
うまい棒買ったんですけど
さすがにこれはスタッフで食べますとは言えないので
ある程度は、あの
僕とか
周りの友達とか皆で食べます！
で、残りは
何か何本か折れちゃってると思うんですけど
折れてない綺麗なやつを
ひょっとしたら皆さんに配れる機会とかを
作るかもしれないので
皆さん
お楽しみに！
うめえか？
つ「美味いです」
ｗ
良かったｗ
つ「ｗｗｗ」